Terms of what we need for this planet to
have a future,
um,
and solve these big issues before it's
too late.
We need two things.
We need this new methodology of some
kind that I mentioned earlier,
uh,
and bringing up a new methodology of
global problem solving,
whether,
whether it's the global issues network
idea that I mentioned or some other idea
that is for the heads of states to
deliver or the prime ministers of this
world to deliver on a.
and individuals in that area can be
active as voters,
as lobbyists,
as civil society and help push towards
that direction.
But the main way in which individuals
can help is with regard to the second
thing.
We need to have a future on this planet.
And that has to do not with
methodological changes,
but with mindset changes.
The type of individual we need from
Iran,
uh,
is an individual who feels that he or
she is first global citizen.
Second,
only a national citizen.
And third,
only a local citizen.
Right now we have it the other way round
in the other way round is deadly for
this planet.
And so we should all try to,
through education systems,
through our children's,
who the next generation pushed for that
sort of mindset.
Because without that new mindset,
that global citizenship mindset,
even a new methodology like the one I
described would not be enough.
You need the combination of the two.